it was just days after Christmas last
year Keith bromyard was told he had
inoperable pancreatic cancer
six weeks later he died without ever
receiving treatment
it took three months from Keith's first
symptoms to his first CT scan delays his
daughter Rebecca believes that reduced
his chances of surviving if it was
picked up sooner would we be in a
different position would we would we be
sat here talking about my dad's survival
rather than my dad's death and so it
does leave a very bitter taste that he
had to wait such a long time to get any
kind of appointment really okay if you
can just bear with me a moment I'm just
going to get his details up on the
screen for the past year Dr trisker and
his team have been taking part in a
trial giving gp's direct access to
diagnostic scams a program Now set to be
rolled out across the country it means
tens of thousands of cancers each year
might be detected earlier leading to
patients getting potentially life-saving
treatment it's something that is really
important to get patients accurate
treatment earlier save lives and it
brings us into line with many of our
world Partners so the UK is something of
an outlier in that GPS don't have access
to direct Imaging tests
GPS and Cancer Care are among the
services facing possible funding Cuts
next year because of a seven billion
pound shortfall in the NHS budget caused
by inflationary pressures but the health
secretary has indicated the NHS will
receive more funding and the
Chancellor's Autumn statements the
chancellor needs to balance through his
fiscal statement The Wider economic
picture built of course within the
Health and Social care sector as with so
many others there are pressures from
inflation Steve Barkley says supporting
the NHS Workforce is a priority but
faced with one of the toughest Winters
in NHS history and with unions across
the sector considering strike action the
demands for extra NHS funding will not
end tomorrow
artist Joshy Sky News